Americans are cursing today more than
ever before in fact the average American
utters 80 to 90 curse words every day
that's about five curse words every
waking hour and it might not be in vain
turns out swearing may help you live a
healthier happier life in the long run
[Music]
when you stub your toe and holler your
favorite dirty four-letter word you're
actually doing yourself a favor
swearing has been known to raise your
heart rate which can help reduce the
pain for example one study found that
people who held their hand in icy water
while cursing lasted 50% longer than
people who used neutral words like
wooden and flat and if you're still not
convinced that you should curse more
consider this swearing could be the key
to improving workouts researchers asked
people to curse while riding a
stationary bike and holding a device
that measured hand grip strength
turns out participants pedaled faster
and gripped stronger while spewing their
favorite expletives and swearing won't
just help you get more fit it can also
reduce stress and anxiety one study
found that swearing helped drivers
better cope with their frustration on
the road whenever a pedestrian illegally
crossed the street and in fact this kind
of emotional relief is so common it has
a name lalu Chee Xia scientists think
that this relief is one reason why we've
evolved to curse in the first place
because it's a way for us to express
strong emotions like anger and
frustration without having to throw a
punch or act out and this method of
choosing words over violence has other
benefits too studies show that people
who curse are perceived as more genuine
and sincere and researchers have found
that people who can list the most swear
words also come across as more honest
when they're measured on a lie scale but
there's still one place where cursing is
almost always out of the question
work but you might have a good excuse to
swear there - hey what the researchers
studied a team of workers at a soap
factory in New Zealand and looked at the
use of one particular swear word starts
with an F it ends with a K I think you
know which word turns out that using the
F word helped workers express politeness
alleviate tension and bond with each
other but we're not saying you should go
and curse out your boss although a
little swearing here and there can't
hurt I mean she might even help
[Music]